scott's cancellation came after last
week's deadly crowd crush at the
astroworld festival in texas madison
kimbrough is live near the las vegas
festival grounds with what people are
saying in regards to their safety
madison
yeah traffic is busy here on the north
end of the strip as you can see people
walking around leaving the festival as
people are still on festival grounds
listening to tonight's headliner post
malone at this very moment so what's the
general consensus of how things are
going
it's day two of day in vegas and people
we've spoken to are pleased with how the
festival has been going thus far
kendrick lamar took the main stage
friday night and post malone took the
stage saturday night in place of travis
scott i think post colon is a good fit a
lot of people are mad about it but i
think it would be good while others said
they would have preferred to see scott
the circumstance of him bowing out was
on the minds of many as safety continues
to be a big concern i was a little bit
scared going at first because of what
happened obviously but i think that i
stayed in the back usually and it was
you know really controlled metro police
working with multiple agencies including
the fbi to prevent any incidents from
happening one festival goer said he was
in the crowd towards the front when he
noticed people voluntarily being pulled
out by security today i noticed a lot
more people were like
being pulled out of the sets when they
wanted to like there were a lot of
security guards literally like pulling
people out metro shared with eight news
now that a lot of preparation went into
properly setting up the stage barriers
and securing them along the main stage
day in vegas organizers said via twitter
that security and safety is always a top
priority working hand in hand with law
enforcement medical personnel and public
safety agencies on protocols for this
weekend
and day in vegas concludes tomorrow at
midnight with tyler the creator as the
headliner reporting live from the strip
madison kimbrough live local now